in this video we are going to learn how
to create a parallax effect for our
webpage so this is the webpage that we
are going to design so when we scroll
down we can see that we have this
parallax effect where this element over
here is moving faster than the image and
we also have a different type of
parallax where the image stays where it
is and the division moves above it so
these are the two different parallax is
that we are going to design and we are
going to use HTML CSS and JavaScript so
let's get started so in my project I
have these three files index dot HTML
main dot J's and style dot CSS and I
also have two different images in my IMG
folder so let's design the HTML markup
we will use M it to create the basic
HTML structure so here we will just give
it a title called parallax and we will
also link our CSS so link and the name
of our CSS file and in our body tag we
will attach our script file so it is
called main dot J's so if you see over
here we can see that we have one two
three and four different divisions so
let's design those divisions so I will
just type div four and it will give me
four different divisions and here I will
create an h2 and I will just type d1 and
I will just copy this so we have our
divisions are setup now we will just
give a basic styling for our website so
first of all we will open this with our
live server so these are the four
divisions will go to our style or CSS
and here first of all we will have a
border of zero and padding of zero and
margin of zero for all the elements and
here we will style all the divisions so
it will have a display of flex and align
items to the center justify content to
the center font weight to bold font
family to Big John and a width of 100%
and a height of 100 viewport height so
these are all our divisions and now we
will style the h2 so I'll type h2 and
here I will give it a font size of 60
pixels and a background color of light
gray a padding of 8 pixels 24 pixels and
border radius of 16 pixels now you'll
style each of the divisions separately
so we will type div and child 1 so this
will select the first division and we
will give it a background image and give
it a URL of d1 dot jpg so this is our
image so you'll give it a background
size of cover so that it will adjust the
size according to the window and now we
will style the second division so div
and child 2 and here we just have to
give a background color of maroon so
this is the second division
now for the third division we will give
a height of 400 pixels
and we'll give a background image and we
will give it a URL of IMG deep
three-door jpg and the background size
should be set to cover and at last the
4th division so and child 4 and we'll
give it a background color of aquamarine
so if we take a look at this we can see
that we have all the divisions styled
properly so first of all I will show you
this basic parallax that we had over
here so this parallax effect where the
divisions moving over it but the image
stays where it is so that is really
simple so we can do it in our CSS itself
so here for our Division 3 we just have
to add one line of code that is
background attachment and set it to
fixed so this will give us that parallax
effect so if you scroll down we can see
that we have this bad Lex effect over
here where the divisions move over it
and the image stays where it is now we
will give the panel X effect that we had
for our Division 1 so that the image
moves bit slower than all the other
elements so for that we have to go to
our JavaScript file so we have already
added our JavaScript file over here
so in our main J's will create a
constant and name it parallax and we
have to access the first division so
what we'll do is create an ID over here
for the division so ID parallax and here
we will say document dot get element by
ID and say parallax over here so this
will fetch this division over here and
now we have to add an event listener for
our window
object so I will have window dot add
eventlistener
and search for the scroll event and
we'll just create an anonymous function
and create a variable called offset and
we will set that equal to window dot
page y offset so this is gonna be the
value of how much the user has crawled
from the top I'll just open my console
so we'll just print the offset value in
our console so here we will type console
dot log and say offset and here we will
type offset so now if we'll save this
and open our console and if we and if we
scroll down we can see we get the value
of offset so this is how much the user
has scroll down so if you scroll down
more you can see we get this value over
here and if we scroll all the way to the
top we get the value of offset to be
zero so this is what we are going to use
in our parallax effect so let me just
show you one more value that we need to
have so I will just console dot log and
this is the offset multiplied by zero
point seven so we will type offset times
zero point seven and now if we scroll
down we can see that we have two
different offset values so this is the
offset and this is offset multiplied by
zero point seven so this is the value
that we get so we are going to use this
value over here to move our image so if
the page is crawled to 36 pixels our
image will be scrolled to 25 point 2
pixels so this is how our code is going
to work so let me just delete
both of these consoles and here we will
type parallax dot style dot background
position Y and we will set that equal to
offset times 0.7 and here we also need
to add pixels so this is our code for
the parallax and now if we go over here
and scroll down we can see that we have
this paddle axe effect over here so this
is how this pad locks works so if we
change this value to save one and now we
can see that the image stays there so it
is just like the fixed property that we
had used over here and if we change
these values to maybe greater than one
so if we change it to 1.5 now if we
scroll we can see that the image moves
in the opposite direction so this is
basically how this panel acts effect
works so let me just change it back to
0.7 which looks fine to me
so this is basically it for this
tutorial I hope that you understood how
to create parallax effect using simple
JavaScript without using all the jQuery
and all those libraries you can use this
simple six lines of JavaScript code and
create this panel x effect and you can
change these values and get different
kinds of effects so if I change it to
0.2 pixels the image will scroll a bit
faster so we can see that over here so
if you have any doubts you can ask them
in the comments below and if you enjoyed
this video please click on the like
button and subscribe to get the latest
updates thanks a lot for watching have a
nice day